E aí
[Música]
e Nós seres humanos somos uma espécie
que ama e que tem o dom de contar
histórias isso já vem de muito tempo a
maioria dos linguistas acreditam que a
origem das histórias data de mais de
meio milhão de anos bom eu tenho o
privilégio de ser uma calculadora de
grandes histórias e de logo em seguida
espalhar oralmente ou em textos e
pensando bem Posso dizer que tudo que
aprendi foi boa parte ouvindo foi
ouvindo Os relatos as histórias as
conversas os sonhos as lutas os ideais
de pessoas que conseguir entender que
existe muita gente boa neste mundo e que
Muitas delas discretamente estão ali
silenciosamente vivendo a próprio dia a
dia cheia de propósito fazendo grandes
revoluções nesse exato momento Estamos
de frente a um dos maiores desafios da
humanidade que nos foi imposto por nós
mesmos o desafio de permanecer vivos
aqui neste incrível o planeta integrando
a fina camada da vida GO e para Assim
como superlativos intensificando as
palavras e justamente porque a fala é o
tipo de comunicação que vai de encontro
direto as nossas emoções que escolhi com
uma minha principal ferramenta de
trabalho além da escrita o meu trabalho
como jornalista me apresentou um dos
maiores paradoxos da minha vida quanto
mais o realismo quanto mais escuto
histórias e quanto mais tem a chance de
vivenciar o poder da natureza mas me
deparo com a emergência da crise
climática com os abismos que ela cria e
criará a beleza que encontra através do
jornalismo é diretamente proporcional
aos grandes problemas que ele me
evidencia às vezes penso que falar sobre
o nosso planeta ao mesmo tempo em que
tudo está por um triz seja um salto
lógico como posso contar as narrativas
tão Poderosas que encontro e vivo
sabendo que temos uma urgência
e os corais estão em risco muito grande
oceanos continentes estão sufocados por
plástico as florestas tropicais estão
sendo engolidas pelo fogo pelo descaso
pelo desmatamento e ainda assim há
pessoas que seguem trabalhando pela
Conservação da natureza
gosto de fazer parte desse time dos que
lutam pela conservação e a minha forma
de inserir é como eu disse espalhando
histórias que possam inspirar Como
podemos fazer para ter ouvidos e para
ser a voz Desse nosso planeta Como
podemos comunicar sobre as emergências
de maneira efetiva e afetiva
Já percebemos que falar sobre crise
climática a partir de um tomar salame
está Invocando o desespero e aumentando
a nossa ansiedade não tem sido
suficiente para criação de uma
consciência coletiva sobre esse tema por
isso passei entender que a maneira como
falamos sobre isso faz toda a diferença
o modo como falamos as narrativas que
contamos e a forma como as e se
recebemos são determinantes para a
criação de uma comunicação efetiva sobre
graves problemas e quando falamos sobre
esse mundo que está em constante
transformação e que ainda pode ser e
permanecer maravilhoso estamos falando
na verdade diretamente com a emoção das
pessoas e é sobre isso que eu vim
conversar com vocês hoje
olha eu já ouvi e já contei muita
história por mês reportagens entrevistas
Produções podia ouvir as vozes do nosso
planeta das mais diferentes formas e
essa minha vocação de escutadora
perguntadora e repórter começou há um
tempo quando eu tinha 19 anos comecei a
trabalhar em uma rádio ir lá como
produtora recebi há relatos de grandes
navegadores que cruzam um oceano
Aventureiros que davam volta ao mundo
que atravessavam os polos ouvir a
mulheres e homens que refazer um grandes
rotas e desafios humanos frente a
natureza e depois eu pegava tudo isso
que chega lá na rede as formas mais
doidas que vocês possam imaginar e as
transformava em Breves narrativas de um
minuto eu precisava trazer toda a emoção
que estava naquela voz e Que contava o
que estava sendo vivido naquele momento
da gravação e assim eu consegui a
transportar os ouvintes para as mais
Incríveis Aventuras em apenas um minuto
aquelas pessoas que nos ouviam
participavam da Jornada de um navegador
que enfrentava ondas de três metros
durante a noite ou se transportavam e
sentindo as dificuldades de escalar as
maiores montanhas as gravações que eu
recebia eram tão marcantes que eu
consigo falar sobre elas mesmo tendo já
se passado mais de 20 anos consigo me
lembrar de detalhes dessas aventuras que
ouvia porque eu senti Me emocionei e
aprendi coisas através delas e
colocá-las no Whats permite aqui outras
pessoas Sonhasse imaginasse o mundo
através das experiências de uma outra
pessoa e esse sonho coletivo senhora
possível porque por trás da que a rádio
curtinhos havia uma linguagem muito
poderosa uma comunicação amorosa sobre o
planeta em que vivemos e isso é
verdadeiramente capaz de nos conectar a
ele uma comunicação que era capaz de
dizer sobre a potência da nossa vida
nesse mundo como parte dessa natureza
ter acesso a algo tão poderoso como
poder sonhar através dessas aventuras
fez tanto sentido para mim que passei a
desejar minhas próprias experiências
Então você é com tá usando a minha
própria voz narrativa sobre a natureza e
sobre quem trabalha por ela descobrir
Histórias Fantásticas e vi porque ainda
podemos e devemos continuar trabalhando
e lutando por nossa vida nele olhar e
perceber como contar histórias de
perspectivas diferentes é algo que
sempre me encantou e assim os 24 anos eu
fui viver em um bar lá fui produtora
repórter e marinheira percorri naquele
veleiro toda a costa brasileira daí a
qualquer XXIII entrando em todas as BA o
e contando sobre a cultura Oceânica do
Brasil essa viagem era transmitida pela
TV e assim conversando entrevistando
conhecendo comecei a mergulhar cada vez
mais nas coisas mínimas nas coisas que a
gente pensa que todos já sabem mas que
na verdade não é assim vivendo a Bordo
descobrir para que servem as donas
descobri que o coral é um animal e que o
Brasil tem um porto de sal que fica em
alto-mar descobrir que temos a maior
extensão de manguezais do mundo que
ficam na Amazônia que o rio Oiapoque
existe assim como o arroio Chuí Fick na
Ilha de Itamaracá existe um guardião do
Forte Orange para cuidar voluntariamente
daquele património e também que existem
as reentrâncias maranhenses onde numa
das ilhas todo dia é um senhor sobe mais
de 300m de escada para acender a luz do
farol que o Delta do Parnaíba no Piauí e
se assemelha a uma mão quadros
embocadura de vários Rios só de falar eu
consigo ver todas essas coisas novamente
e talvez muitos de vocês estejam também
imaginando o viajando com isso lembrando
talvez algum lugar fantástico do Brasil
que conhece e que deve ser preservado
bonito isso né estamos aqui jun
Relembrando imaginando nos emocionando
criando conexões que estão acontecendo
neste momento Esse é o poder da
comunicação EA emoção é a fresta que eu
encontrei nela na comunicação do Porque
devemos nos preocupar com tudo aquilo
que garante a nossa permanência na terra
infelizmente a conta já chegou para
grande parte da humanidade e boa parte
das pessoas já não têm escolha Você já
ouviram falar que a gente perdeu a
conexão com a natureza né você já devem
ter ouvido falar muitas vezes parei para
perguntar Em que momento isso aconteceu
e cheguei a uma conclusão depois de
muito ouvir estudar sobre isso um desses
momentos E aí quando começamos acelerar
o tempo e impor a todas as demais
espécies ou seja para ter uma melhor
produtividade
aceleramos e criamos desperdício na
produção de quase tudo de alimentos até
roupas estamos tornando o planeta doente
e exaurido o poder transformador da
Palavra Falada da comunicação amorosa
como eu chão é o que eu acredito que
pode nos ajudar a não desistir não quero
que ficar aparecendo que estou falando
de que não temos que olhar para a
realidade é justamente contrário é
encarando a realidade que cada um de nós
busca ou deveria buscar soluções para o
desafio socioambiental que nos metemos
como não sucumbe sabendo que sabemos uma
vez fiz essa pergunta um líder indígena
do Vale do Javari EA resposta dele foi
uma das coisas mais fortes e norteadores
para mim liguei para ele falar armada
pelos índices de desmatamento tava muito
impactada bem o e perguntava aí agora o
que que a gente vai fazer como seguir
adiante porque seguir adiante e ele me
respondeu Olha a Paulina vou te dizer o
que o meu avô sempre disse para mim
mereça viver não é forte o que você está
fazendo hoje para merecer viver neste
planeta que ainda guarda espécies que
não conhecemos que ainda pode nos
maravilhar com a beleza então essas
histórias que também quero contar e
conto são histórias de pessoas que
podemos ensinar sobre um planeta natural
que ainda guarda resquícios do que era
sem o impacto humano aprende o quanto de
diversidade podemos contabilizar dentro
de uma floresta a partir do Canto de uma
ave e porque um animal como Muriqui o
maior macaco das Américas pode nos
ensinar a ser uma sociedade melhor aqui
um parênteses os muriquis são primatas
que se abraçam se cuidam vivem numa
sociedade paz e amor igualitária demais
aprendi com outras mulheres na
conservação que a res e é algo
importante e que a grande inspiração vem
do exemplo e eu ouvir histórias como
essas de pessoas que seguem trabalhando
pela Conservação da maior biodiversidade
do planeta apesar de tudo que tá
acontecendo
entendemos o porquê é importante que a
beleza do mundo seja preservada e Por
que devemos nos comportar como uma
espécie que quer deixar seus
descendentes como me disseram duas
outras pesquisadas
elas assim como eu imagino que vocês
também Queremos continuar sonhando com o
planeta que ainda tem a Antas Araras
muriquis baleias florestas manguezais
grandes Dunas a limpo água fruta no pé
onça para hoje e para amanhã
gosto de ouvir e de dar voz a pessoas
que possam nos resgatar nos trazer de
volta à como era olhavamos e pensávamos
em soluções baseadas na natureza sim
porque para quase todas as perguntas as
respostas
a
natureza perceberam como até agora eu
contei muitas histórias foram elas essas
histórias sobre o nosso planeta
extraordinário que pulsa a vida e guarda
ainda tantos segredos que me lembram a
todo tempo da importância de cuidarmos
dele por isso acredito que uma
comunicação que se conecta direto a
emoção consciente disso é fundamental
para que a gente consiga despertar uma
consciência coletiva sobre a urgência de
nós preservarmos no planeta talvez
através dessas incríveis e histórias a
gente consiga se lembrar do com valioso
é estar aqui para finalizar queria
contar para vocês algo que me fortalece
e me enche de coragem toda vez que eu
uso jovens e povos indígenas que estão
na linha de frente da sua luta me
ensinaram aqui para que a gente Crie e
viva o mundo melhor é preciso primeiro
sonhá-lo e quem sabe se estivermos
abertos para ouvir as vozes do planeta
não conseguimos criar um sonho comum eu
espero que não deixamos de nos encantar
com essas vozes vamos nessa né
E aí